en un intento por impulsar a Ucrania el
pentágono confirmó el inicio de
entrenamientos a soldado sucranianos en
una base militar del estado de Oklahoma
la capacitación se enfocará en la
operación y el mantenimiento del
poderoso sistema de defensa antiaéreo
patreon luego de los insistentes pedidos
de quiefa Washington para protegerse de
los ataques rusos es entrenamiento
durará varios meses y entrenará de 90 a
100 ciudadanos en el uso del sistema de
misiles patreon las tropas ya se
encuentran en la base de forcel y
comenzaron su capacitación
el sistema
de defensa aéreo más avanzado de Estados
Unidos capaz de derribar misiles
balísticos y aeronaves entre 70 y 130
kilómetros de distancia este
entrenamiento hace parte del paquete de
ayuda a Ucrania anunciado por Estados
Unidos en diciembre por 1850 millones de
dólares Durante los últimos meses Rusia
ha atacado infraestructuras cruciales en
Ucrania interrumpiendo el de
Electricidad agua y calefacción a
millones de personas además de golpear
estructuras civiles el Primer Ministro
en Irlandés visitó Washington y dijo que
su país está considerando unirse a la
iniciativa en la que también participa
Alemania luego de iniciar un envío del
sistema a la frontera de Ucrania con
Polonia hemos decidido dar otros 2.500
millones para ayudar al esfuerzo de la
Guerra de Ucrania
tenemos la intención de unirnos a lo que
está haciendo Alemania en los proyectos
los misiles son desarrollados por la
empresa estadounidense raidón Y
actualmente se encuentran desplegados en
al menos 17 países